على الطلبه وشباب عاملين في تركيا
جمعيات مؤسسات منظمات شفنا انه دور لازم
نقف مع اهلنا اللي بتركيا اللي هم وقفوا
معنا من قبل فشفنا عليها لازم نرجعه فاحنا
كونا فريق من هذه المنظمات وعملنا حمله
نحن نعمل الان مع وقف الخيرات تعاملنا مع
وقف تركي لوقف الخيرات من اقدم الاوقاف
الداعمه في تركيا هذه العوائل لما تهدمت
دورها كلها اصبحت نازحه فاحنا نقدمنهم
الاشياء اللي ضروريه اللي يحتاجوها
بحياتهم ما تخليهم يحتاجون لاحد يعني من
ما من معكرونه من حليب من وجبات غذاء ثلاث
وجبات غداء غذاء في اليوم كل هذه وجبات
نقدمها للاهل بطانيات ايضا ومستلزمات اخرى
حتى حفاضات للاطفال المنطقه يعني عباره عن
شيء اول شيء اول مره اول مره ارى فيها
يعني الاف البدايه المدمره المهدمه الناس
بائسه الوجوه بائسه تقريبا في كل عماره
هناك ناس تنتظر يطلعون احد ممكن يكون بعد
عاي
العراق ما عندهم اماكن ما عندهم سكن يعني
وضعهم جدا صعب احنا نحاول نقدم نقدر عليه
احنا اخذنا على انفسنا انه نستمر لاخر يوم
لكن نحن يعني نطلب دعم الناس وحتى نقدر
الدعم نستديم هذه الخدمه المقدمها وهي
مفيده جدا لكن كل هذه الجهود لحد الان
اعتقد انها غير كافيه لانها كل شيء فهي
محدوده يعني احنا نوفر طبعا لكن كيف توفر
مثلا المغاسل للناس كيف يتوفر لهم مثلا
ماكن للمبيت هذا اعتقد هناك في قصور ايضا
لكن نحتاج دعم ايضا يحتاج دعم اكثر واكثر
واكثر